Can whites increase our birth rates in the
absence of religion?
What about a patriarchal society that respects
male reproductive rights?
Well, the very short answer to that is no,
you do need religion.
And obviously, you need religion either because
religion is real,
in some metaphysical sense, and necessary
to people's well-being and happiness,
Or (and this is not necessarily an incompatible
view), we are evolved towards devotion and
faith,
as a means of increasing the amount of binding
energy within a group,
thus increasing the efficiency of the group,
in intergroup competition.
So you always need religion.
So far, nobody's really been able to come
up with a viable substitute for religion,
as a source of organic cohesion within social
groups.
So it seems that given human metaphysical
and genetic limitations,
we very likely need religion,
and will continue to need religion going forwards
into the future.
Yes, first of all, people that don't have
religion seem to have lower fertility,
so they will die out.
Secondly, people that don't have religion,
tend to have higher mental instability.
I don't necessarily mean this is causal,
but they tend to have higher mental instability,
higher depression, higher Autism.
Thirdly, groups that don't have religion are
less ethnocentric,
are less likely to fight for their own interests,
and will get selected out.
As I said before, there is actually a specific
part of the brain called the anterior frontal
cortex,
which is associated both with religiousness
and ethnocentrism.
And when you stimulate it with magnets, it
elevates both.